Hi, today I am speaking
with Veronika Mark.
I've spoken to her before and,
uh, she is a bit of a globe
trotter, as we will soon discover.
And we are going to talk about
English as an international language.
And, uh, Veronika...
first of all, if you say, if you
enjoy these videos, please subscribe.
Click on the bell for notifications,
and if you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a comment.
Hi Veronika.
Nice to see you again.
Yeah, hi thank you.
Thank you for inviting me here.
All right.
So, uh, let, first of all, let's
catch catch up on your history
since the last time we spoke.
So many of our listeners won't realize
just by listening to you that you're
not a native speaker of English.
Your English is phenomenal, but of course
you're not a native speaker of English.
You're an example of
international English.
And, which is gonna be the subject of our
conversation, but update us on, on what
has happened to you since we last spoke.
Yeah.
So since we last spoke, I moved to a
different country because um, yeah,
last time I was living in Russia, in
Moscow, I was actually learning Chinese.
I was still a college student.
Right now, I'm not a
college student anymore.
I graduated from college and, uh,
I'm just working on YouTube, making
videos for people to learn English.
And, uh, right now I live in Mexico City.
Yeah.
So a lot has changed.
Yeah, what is the, uh, name
of your YouTube channel?
So I have two YouTube channels.
The one where I teach people English
is called English with Veronika Mark.
And uh, the second one is just
Veronika Mark, just my name.
and what, what's different
between the two channels?
The difference is, uh, English with
Veronika Mark is focused on teaching
people English, so I share tips on
how I manage to improve my English.
I help people improve their
English, and Veronika Mark
is just lifestyle, basically.
I speak English there too, but it's
more like, oh, I went traveling there,
you know, follow me or I did this.
It's more like lifestyle content.
Okay, so, and you said
you were learning Chinese.
Are you still learning Chinese and
are you learning any other languages
or do you speak other languages?
Um, no, not anymore.
Actually, when I graduated from
college, I stopped learning Chinese just
because I, I had to move to a different
country, Mexico, and I didn't speak
Spanish at all at first, so now I'm
learning Spanish, like every single day.
So this is definitely my
goal to learn, uh, Spanish.
how good is your Spanish right now?
If you go out into the street, if you
need, uh, you know, help in finding
your way, or you walk into a store
or perhaps friends that you have, are
you able to function in in Spanish?
Yeah,
I'll be okay.
Yeah, my Spanish is not amazing.
Definitely not.
I've been learning for
like six months now.
, Uhhuh, but yeah.
Yeah, I, I know my way
around it, I would say.
.
Oh, good.
Okay.
Now, it's interesting, uh, I was
just chatting with someone and how
the most commonly spoken languages
in the world are, of course, the
languages of the imperialists, call it.
The empires, you know?
Why do people, so many people
speak English, French, Spanish,
Portuguese, Russian, uh, Quechua
even in Latin America, which
was spread by the Inca Empire.
So, uh, empires tend to
spread their language.
uh, but perhaps no language has become
as dominant as the English language.
So, because for me, English is,
it's essentially my native language.
Although I was born in Sweden, but
since the age of five I've lived in
Canada, so as a non-native speaker
of English, what is the attitude
of the person learning English?
Do they learn it out of necessity?
Do they learn it out of interest?
Uh, what's the attitude towards this idea
that this language above all others, a
language which is no better than any other
originally spoken by people who live on
this foggy island in the North Atlantic?
Why do we have to learn English?
Like what is the range of feelings
that people have when they are
confronted with having to learn English?
I think right now it's mostly out
of necessity because uh, even when
it comes to your hobbies, if you're
interested in, um, cooking, there
is so many recipes in English.
If you're a professional athlete and
you wanna like advance in your career,
you will have to learn English just
to be able to travel, to communicate
to different coaches, for example.
So I think right now, Even if a person
is just like, oh, I like English.
I'm interested in English.
But one day they will
have to, they will con...
like they will have to, um, I
would say they will, they will be
in this situation where they will
like, okay, like I need English.
I need English for
work, for, um, Studying.
I wanna study at a better university,
or I just wanna move to a different
country and I need English.
Yeah.
Now the sort of learning out of necessity,
that's not necessarily a great motivator.
It's at least it's not
a positive motivation.
It's almost a negative motivation.
So does the average, from your
experience, and you have a lot of
people who follow you on YouTube,
are people able to find some positive
motivation, something positive about
learning English that encourages
them, encourages them along the way.
Yeah, that's, uh, very interesting
actually, because I feel like this
is something that I'm experiencing
with Spanish right now because I
started learning Spanish because of
necessity, because I had to, in Mexico
City, yes, you can just live with
English, but it will be very difficult.
So I would say that yes, it's not
enough of a motivation to learn
in languages because of necessity.
And I think, uh, people who follow me
on YouTube or Instagram, most of them
learn English because of necessity.
But I think what makes the
journey a lot more enjoy...
enjoyable is finding
resources that they like.
For example, um, what helped me, I
learned English because of necessity,
because of my, um, education in college.
I had a lot of subjects in English,
so I would, at home, I would
like watch YouTube in English.
And for me that was something that
would give me a lot of enjoyment
and pleasure and satisfaction.
I'd be like, oh, I love it.
This is the way I like learning English.
So even though for most of my
subscribers, yes, it's like, I
need English because of my work.
However, the paths they take
are often like different.
Some people are like, oh, I only
wanna focus on business English,
but are the people like, no.
Like I'm okay with exploring
different subjects, different,
using different resources.
So I guess it just depends on the person.
Yeah.
And I would say too, that if you really
try to just focus on business English,
you won't succeed in other words.
We have to have a general, broadly based
sense of the language before we can start
focusing in on, on business English.
I, I always laugh when people are,
we're gonna teach you business English.
There's English.
You've gotta learn English.
Um, and it, it's quite true that, that
in every language, you know, if you're in
the beginner material, a lot of the people
who write textbooks try and push stuff
at you that they think you should know.
You should know these Japanese festivals.
You should know, you should be interested
in this or that people might be interested
in something completely different.
So nowadays you're able to find stuff
of interest and uh, you know, I always
quote the French expression ... the
appetite comes with the eating.
And once you get into a language,
then you discover things
that are of interest to you.
But it remains that English is the
language with perhaps the greatest amount
of content available on the internet.
Spanish is not bad, is very good.
Russian, by the way, has a lot of stuff.
Uh, you know, and, and particularly
for me that I enjoy 19th century
literature, you can find books for free.
Yeah.
And, uh, excellent quality
audiobook produced in Russia.
And so different languages...
on the other hand, Persian and
Arabic is a lot harder to find stuff.
And, um, it, it is important and it's
very helpful when there's an abundance
of, of content, hopefully with audio
and text available that something in
there is gonna be of interest to you.
Another subject on English, you know,
sometimes you hear, well, you know
this Anglo-Saxon imperialism and
everybody speaking English is no good,
so we should all learn Esperanto.
I have trouble with that because I
personally find Esperanto, like I've
never met a native speaker of Esperanto.
Now people are coming on oh, yes I
know so and so, he raised his kids
on Esperanto, but that's not true.
Uh, there's no culture there.
There's no food, there's no
place called Esperanto land.
So we're kind of, we're
we're left with English.
And if you get on a plane, as happened
to me, I was in Brazil flying from
Iguazú to Rio, and the fellow sitting
beside me was a Ukrainian who had been
living in Brazil and we spoke Ukrainian.
You're, you're not gonna sit beside,
you're far more likely to find
someone sitting beside you on an
airplane who speaks English than
just about any other language.
And so, like it or not, you know, we're
stuck with English and it is kind of
useful, uh, but I can see where people who
are not native speakers feel it unfair.
Do you sometimes think it's unfair
that everyone has to learn English?
Why doesn't everyone learn
Spanish or Russian, or Chinese?
Oh, well, this question of whether
or not it's unfair, I just think
that life is unfair in general.
Like when people try to be like,
oh, it's fair, or it's unfair.
I mean, it is how it is and there
is nothing we can do about it.
If you just sit there and say, oh, it's
unfair, like we have to learn English.
Why not my native language?
Well, you either just sit there
and whine about it, or you actually
go and learn English, because
English will always be there.
People will always be learning
English and uh, Yeah, that's it.
Like unfortunately, that's
the reality we'll live in.
So you either learn English
or you don't learn it.
I mean, it's your choice.
You miss the point.
Yeah, and, and it's not really
a political statement either.
If a, if a Japanese person meets someone
from Brazil, they're gonna speak English.
It's just a practical matter.
This is, how else are
they gonna communicate?
The Brazilian is unlikely
to speak Japanese.
The Japanese person is
unlikely to speak Portuguese.
So it's, they can use their hands and,
and gestures, or they can speak English.
So, yeah, I agree with you.
It's, it's a practical solution.
There are regional languages like, but
even there, I think in Latin America...
yeah they can speak to each other
in Portuguese and Spanish, and they
more or less understand each other.
So that's, that's okay too.
Yeah.
So what are your plans now?
You're going to continue with
your platform on YouTube.
And you're gonna learn span Spanish.
When you become as fluent in
Spanish as you are now in English,
are you gonna start, uh, YouTube
channel for learning Spanish?
Um, I haven't thought about it
yet to be completely honest.
Uh, when it comes to English for sure,
I wanna continue making videos because I
mean, even right now as I am a non-native
English speaker, I can see how much I
have improved since our last video, for
example, because I watched, like our last
interview a couple of days ago was like,
wow, my English is a lot better right now.
So making videos in English on YouTube
has definitely helped me a lot.
Um, when it comes to Spanish, uh, probably
not because, um, it's enough for me with
just one language, just sharing my journey
with people because I have been learning
English basically in my whole life.
With Spanish, it's more like I don't
wanna get super, super advanced.
I just wanna be able to live in Mexico
City and, uh, use some phrases in
Spanish, and I think that's enough for me.
Okay.
And, and we can end on that note, however,
if you were to do a video about your
struggles in learning Spanish as an adult,
uh, I think it would be quite interesting.
Yeah.
Because.
I mean, as you say, you've been
learning English your whole life.
There's a lot of English in schools
everywhere around the world.
Now you go to a country where they speak
Spanish, which you didn't have at school.
And so you're starting from scratch
and, and what's that experience like?
It would be an interesting, uh, and, and
showcase a bit of Mexico City and stuff.
That would be fun.
Anyway, that's entirely up to you.
So, but at any rate, thank you for taking
the time and, uh, I think your level
of English is astounding and yes, even
better than it was before . Uh, and I
think that illustrates several things.
First of all, I mean, I can detect
traces, uh, of sort of non-native,
the slightest, slightest suggestion
that you're not, um, a native speaker.
But your English is astounding.
And the biggest thing to me is that I
have the feeling that no matter what
I say, no matter how quickly I speak,
you will understand everything I say.
And that is the, to my mind, the
most important goal is comprehension,
because for the native speaker,
speaking to someone where you have
the impression, they don't really
understand you, that's very unsatisfying.
That's not a good feeling.
Whereas I can talk to you as
soon as I want and you can
understand everything I say.
That is, that's very, very good.
And you have definitely improved.
So no matter how good we
are, we can always improve.
That's the other message.
Yeah.
And I know that as a non-native speaker, I
will always be improving as long as I uh,
study English, I will always be getting
better and also actually recording myself,
like having all of those videos or even
like quick audio messages that I sent to
other people that I can later refer to
motivates me a lot because I'm like, oh
my God, a year ago I sounded like this.
Like I didn't know all of these words,
but now I feel so much more confident.
I speak a lot faster.
I know all of these words.
So yeah, like having all of those,
uh, videos and all of those references
really does help me, like motivate
me to study English even more.
And you know, it's not only the
fact that you know all these
words, the way you assemble your
words is in the correct order.
Uh, so many people, and it, it,
that's more important than accent
is, is having a sentence structure
with the odd clause buried in another
clause, but yet everything is English.
It's not Russian, or it's
not German or Chinese.
It's, it's actually a
hundred percent English.
Yes.
So, congratulations.
Thank you.
All right.
Thank you, Veronika.
Nice chatting.
Thank you.
Yeah, thank you.
Bye
bye-bye.